Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
There's a brand new Deadpool
3 teaser with a whole bunch of footage,
a whole bunch of previews to break down.
There's a bunch of scenes they've been filming,
and it looks like a bunch of classic
X-Men are back partaking only the Sabretooth character.
But not just any Sabertooth, the classic Tyler Mane
sabertooth in a bunch of Easter eggs
from other Marvel movies seemingly confirming
where a lot of this is taking place during the movie.
So of course we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I'll do a special Deadpool
three giveaway when we get closer to some more footage
actually coming out they move the Marvel movies
just a little bit next year.
So like Deadpool three is the only live action
Marvel movie coming out next year in 2024.
That's how confident they are about it.
Also, they were almost done
filming the movie when the strikes happened,
so it was just like a little bit of filming left to do.
I was a part of it was this huge battle scene
with a lot of the classic X-Men characters
and apparently some fantastic Four Easter eggs
here too, and some classic Captain America Easter eggs.
so, just starting at the beginning of the footage here,
the footage itself,
like all of the collective footage in the scenes,
make it seem like they really are on the Void planet
from the Loki series that we saw
where everything gets dumped when they get pruned
also zoom in, enhancing in the background here.
There's a lone TVA agent seemingly confirming all this,
like the TVA is present when this is all going down.
in that's how they wind up with stuff
from a bunch of different Marvel movies
all repurposed Mad Max style Deadpool and Wolverine
Beyond the Thunderdome
they start with a bunch of scenes of Deadpool
in Wolverine versus Sabretooth.
But like I said, it's
the classic version of Sabretooth from the X-Men
2000 movie, the Bryan Singer version of Sabretooth,
played by Tyler Mane
The actor doesn't look like Tyler Main, though,
like Zoom Hands.
maybe this is just a stunt double
they're using on set for the action scenes
and they swap in Tyler Mayne's face with CG.
Leave Schreiber's saber to from Wolverine origins
was also supposed to be featured
somewhere in the movie.
you know. You know what? That makes this a reunion for
X-Men Origins Reunite.
Yeah, I'm guessing they're not doing any kind of weird
tricky thing here.
Like this version of Sabretooth is meant to eventually
look like the Tyler Mane version of Sabertooth.
it's not like leave.
Schreiber Sabertooth dressed up as Tyler Mane
Sabretooth, Notice
When Wolverine and Sabertooth charge at each other,
they go full claws on claws, ripping at each other.
But notice when Sabretooth stops, right?
When he gets to Deadpool, there's a bit of a time jump.
Then we see that he's been
with Deadpool picking his head up off the ground
and showing it to everyone like, Hey, this is awesome.
Look, everybody.
so it kind of seems like Deadpool
is the one to actually kill him with his sword
in one of the other swords is stuck inside
Wolverine's chest this whole time.
So like, when he's charging it, Tyler and Sabretooth,
he's got one of Deadpool's swords stuck in his chest.
Still.
So it seems like the way this fight goes down.
Deadpool Wolverine have been fighting each other.
I already did a video about that scene
because they filmed it before the strike,
so I'll link it at the end of this.
It's actually pretty cool. It's
exactly what you would expect it to be.
they go at each other
full till just hacking away body parts.
I think Wolverine slices some of Deadpool's
body parts off and throws them at him
end, while they're busy, tiring each other out
because they both have healing factors,
the fight would just go on forever theoretically
because they just heal all the damage.
they eventually just get bored of it
and get tired of fighting each other.
and it seems like suddenly, like right
as that's happening, a bunch of the other X-Men
characters from the classic X-Men
movies show up but it's brotherhood of mutants.
Characters from that movie, like the villains
there are a bunch of people,
but the most identifiable ones here are Tylor means
Sabertooth and Toad, played by Ray Park,
who was Toad in the original X-Men movie.
this does look like Ray Park is actually walking around
on set filming this scene.
but then we have this whole other dimension
to this scene where we get to
the whole like, Loki void planet
and all this stuff from other Marvel movies
Notice the cars that the brotherhood of mutants
are driving are all from other Marvel movies.
They've all been modified Mad Max style
because this looks kind of like a wasteland.
We literally just got a brand new Mad
Max movie trailer, and Chris Hemsworth is in
that movie is one of the villains.
talk about your meta Marvel Easter egg moments.
one of them is driving the cupcake truck
from the new night series.
It's been souped up to make it more tank
like the other one is Red Skull's Car
from the first Captain America movie
that's been hot with a giant gun attached to it,
Now the gun looks like it's either
from Thanos, the ship in Avengers Endgame,
or one of the Qatari blasters
from the first Avengers movie.
it might also be one of those special
souped up blasters that Red Skull was making
during the original Captain America movie,
The Hydra Blasters, based on the Tesseract power.
and it gets even crazier because the third car we see
is actually the fantastic car
from the classic Fantastic Four movie.
But here's the thing.
It's actually based on a version of the classic one
from the comics,
not from the classic Fantastic Four movie.
this is the original version
that debuted in the comics back in the sixties.
The fantastic car in the original Fantastic
Four, Silver Surfer movie in the early
2000s was a more modern
looking design with a Dodge logo on it.
what might be happening here
is that they're just canonizing some of the classic
animated Fantastic Four TV shows with this.
But maybe this is based on some unused concept art
from the old Fantastic Four movies.
Let me know in the comments what you think it is.
they're couple other Mad Max style souped up vehicles
from the brotherhood of mutants that are driving here
but they're more military like like there's a tank
that looks like a communications truck.
I can't tell which Marvel movies these are from.
one of the vehicles
pulling it here is Captain America's classic motorcycle
from the first Captain America movie.
You can let me know where you think
some of these other motorcycles come from.
I'm guessing other Marvel movies as well to.
There's like another tank here with a cage on it, too.
So it seems like Deadpool
Wolverine get captured at some point during this.
maybe some of these are from the incredible Hulk movie
or the classic
Hulk movie just because they had traditional
military vehicles in that.
it just seems like whatever fight
they wind up having slows down here
when the rest of them show up, they take Wolverine
and Deadpool back to wherever their base is.
so like I said, I think the idea is the reason
why all these Easter eggs from different Marvel
movies are showing up is because
this is the Void planet where a bunch of Nexus
events get dumped when they get pruned
in at least part of this movie is taking place.
After the events of Loki season two.
part of the idea, though, is the Deadpool three
is meant to directly set up Avengers six secret wars.
Not as much Qing Dynasty set up as Secret War, set up
with all the incursions,
destroying the multiverse,
and then winding up on a version of battle world.
supposedly all the reports are saying right now
is that the TVA is trying to save
as many people as possible from across the multiverse,
putting them on one of the last
remaining worlds to survive in the multiverse
because of all the incursions, the time runs out.
Storyline from the Secret Wars, comics in that world
is going to be a version
of Battle world from the comics.
So I think that they're actually talking
about the void playing it like that
battle world
winds up being a version of the Void Planet.
no. It's not totally clear
how Wolverine and Deadpool wind up here.
Like if they get pruned by the TVA and sent here.
But for instance,
you see the remnants of the 20th Century Fox logo.
The whole idea is the movie is meant to be kind
of a version of Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe.
But as Deadpool kills the Fox Marvel Universe,
which is why there's a bunch of Fox Marvel Easter eggs
here from different movies,
especially the classic movies
like classic Fantastic Four, the classic X-Men movies.
there's still a couple of Marvel TV series
that are premiering next year,
particularly because we're talking about a lot of X-Men
coming back during Deadpool three X-Men.
97 episodes will be happening next year,
not till after the Echo episodes are done
at the beginning of the year,
but we might get those X-Men 97 episodes by the spring
there's a bunch of other stuff going on in the movie
too, like Jean Gray is supposed to be coming back.
Cyclops is supposed to be coming back
for those original X-Men movies.
We're supposed to get Ian McKellen
classic Magneto back,
and they'll be all wearing more comic book
looking versions of their costumes
from different universes,
not from the original X-Men universe.
that's mostly how they're avoiding trampling
on the canon of those classic
X-Men movies, Like they're riffing on a lot of this
because it's all multiverse.
Like you're bringing the actors back,
but they're all from other universes,
so you can do whatever you want to with the characters
without completely Retconning those original movies.
that's how they're planning to avoid messing
with the plot of the Logan movie.
That was their big deal, too.
Like we're bringing it back right after we killed him.
But it's going to be a completely different version
of the character.
I literally just did a video about
how they're supposedly bringing X 23 back Laura Kinney
from that movie to she she'd also be an older version
because obviously Daphne Queen is much older now.
She looks way older from another universe as well.
part of the plot of the movie is supposed
to be Wolverine jumping around the multiverse
with cable's time travel device
looking for the perfect version of Wolverine.
It is meant to be them sort of clowning on the idea
that Kevin Fire is eventually going to recast
the Wolverine character from Hugh Jackman,
all the other classic X-Men actors to
they just started talking about the brand new X-Men
movie that Kevin begins working on with Marvel Studios.
We're not going to see that for a couple of years,
like it's going to be a while before
we get more news about that.
There's a lot of classic X-Men
that are coming back before that, but they're kind of
using Deadpool three as a sort of
no way home like Spider-Man, no way home,
bringing back the classic actors
before they recast a lot of these people.
Deadpool, No way Home, X-Men, No Way Home.
But you also have a lot of classic Fantastic
Four people coming back to.
We will see the new Fantastic
Four movie, Much, much Faster.
for those of you asking if the new X-Men 97 episodes
are going to be Canon to the MCU,
they'll be canon in the way that the
What if series is can add to the MCU.
Like what if is a multiverse show.
We've seen some of the animated
what if characters show up in live action,
but it's slightly different versions of the characters.
the way that Marvel has explained
is that what is taking place
in like a different part of the multiverse,
but because theoretically the multiverse is infinite,
like we saw in the Loki series, it is infinite.
it's really easy to explain
how some of those characters can be often
like one part of the multiverse.
And then you have like all the 616, the main MCU stuff,
all the related like Spider-Man,
no way home stuff with their multiverse, even the venom
universes all in other parts of the multiverse.
They don't necessarily crossover
with a what if stuff, at least yet.
so all the X-Men 97 stuff
is meant to be in their own universe too,
from that original series
like it'll be season six of X-Men, the animated series.
They're just calling it X-Men 97 for whatever guild
like behind the scenes purposes, business purposes.
that's why when you look at all of the scenes
here, it's
meant to look kind of like the original artwork
from that X-Men.
The animators there is but done with modern technology,
so it looks way crisper.
We'll probably get a trailer for that
in the next couple of months after
What if season two episodes are done?
That'll be like the next big thing I'll be doing videos
for in the next couple of weeks.
We'll get all those episodes
right before the end of the year.
we probably won't get a full Deadpool
three official trailer
till like early next year, maybe like spring next year
because movies coming out in summer.
So they'll probably start promoting it
pretty soon at the beginning of next year.
At some point.
there were a bunch of trailers
that dropped over the weekend because it was XP.
Click here to learn about x 23 coming back in Deadpool
three and then click here for all my trailer
videos in the weekend like Boy Season 4,
House of the Dragon Season 2, everything.
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one1